pourquoi lorsqu'on veut faire quelque
chose il ya toujours quelqu'un pour vous
dire ce n'est pas possible je vois que
ça parle à certains c'est bien j'ai
grandi au liban comme la plupart des
enfants de mon âge
mes héros s'appelaient tom sawyer
indiana jones
marty mcfly mais mon passe temps favori
c'était de collectionner les éclats
d'obus
les cartouches de balle et les caisses
de munitions un jour j'ai trouvé le
graal une grenade encore actives je
sentais bien
quand la ramenant à la maison mes
parents seraient pas vraiment fier de
moi autant vous dire je n'ai pas garder
très longtemps
lorsqu'on est enfant
rien ne nous semble impossible un jour
nos parents nous ont annoncé qu ont
quitté le liban pour la france et par la
route avec les yeux d'un enfant libanais
la france c'est carrément une planète
c'est pas comme ça que vous voyez la
france il ya les châteaux de la loire
mais je peux vous dire que au liban à 9
ans c'était vrai pour moi mais c'était
vrai également pour mes amis
la france c'est ça et bien en arrivant
en france
mes parents nous avaient offert et pour
la première fois de ma vie
la démonstration qu'une chose
parfaitement inconcevable pouvait se
produire par le plus grand des hasards
on est arrivé en france à 14 juillet
plus grand des hasards mes souvenirs
sont un peu floues mais je me souviens
de la promenade des anglais à nice pour
ceux qui se situent pas la foule
le feu d'artifice c'était la première
fois que je voyais un feu d'artifice au
liban bien sûr on sait fêter dignement
un événement au liban lorsqu'on veut
fêter un événement c'est simple on tirs
à la kalachnikov et on apprend le soir
qu'il ya eu deux ou trois morts suite à
des balles perdues c'est notre bouquet
final
adolescent j'ai rejoint les scouts je me
suis retrouvé dans un groupe de sportifs
il était immense émoi
enfin c'est aux scouts où j'ai appris la
notion d'effort et de dépassements et
puis ça m'a donné envie d'aller plus
loin de faire d'autres projets je me
suis lancé dans l'alpinisme
à cette époque j'étais étudiant alors
pour pouvoir faire de l'alpinisme il
fallait que je gagne de l'argent
je me suis mis à donner des cours de
maths chaque centime me rapprocher petit
à petit de mon objectif chaque euro
gagné c'était un peu plus près de mon
projet est de mon objectif
on a commencé à expliquer que je pouvais
pas entreprendre un tel projet je
n'avais aucune expérience je ne
connaissais rien à la montagne j'étais
pas dans la case alpinistes alors j'ai
quand même fait un certain nombre de
projets j'ai fait plusieurs ascensions
plusieurs sommets bien sûr tout ne s'est
pas toujours passé comme prévu
en argentine par exemple alors que je
tentais l'ascension du plus haut sommet
de l'hémisphère sud qui s'appelle
l'aconcagua a pratiquement sept mille
mètres d'altitude
j'ai dû abandonner à 400 mètres du
sommet 400 m c'est probablement la
distance qui vous sépare vous ici de
votre voiture sur le parking
400 m après deux ans de préparation et
15000 kilomètres parcourus vous pensez
certainement que j'étais déçu eh bien je
vais vous dire en fait j'étais soulagé
soulager pourquoi parce que bon nombre
de gens m'avaient expliqué que
l'alpinisme salle est difficile j'aurais
froid j'aurais fin j'aurais peur mais
personne n'a eu la présence d'esprit de
me dire que peut-être partir faire un
sommet comme ça à l'autre bout du monde
en pleine période de noël pouvait être
difficile et à l'autre bout du monde
je me suis senti terriblement seul mais
ça m'a quand même donné envie de
continuer ça n'a pas empêché de
poursuivre mes projets alors j'ai
remonté d'autres projets d'autres
aventures j'ai entre autres fait un tour
du monde à la force humaine alors force
humaine ça veut dire quoi
et bien c'est simple enfin pour ainsi
dire
j'ai fait la moitié de la terre à vélo
et l'autre moitié avec un kayak et un
bateau qu'il avance est qu en pédalant
oui c'est pas bien compliqué à nouveau
la plupart des gens pour pas dire cette
fois ci tout le monde m'a expliqué que
je ne pouvais pas réussir un tel projet
je n'avais pas le mental je ne
connaissais rien à la mer je n'étais pas
dans la case marins les objections ont
été nombreuses il ya même une fois une
journaliste qui m'a interpellé
je vous propose de vous le faire ça va
être plus drôle oui alors on reçoit bon
jour on reçoit aujourd'hui au jean
gabriel chelala jean gabriel chelala
vous envisagez de partir pour un tour du
monde extraordinaire alors une première
question m'arrive là comme ça tout de
suite
vous pensez vraiment pouvoir parcourir
trente trois mille kilomètres on n'y en
pas un physique de sportif
bon il faut savoir que c'était une des
toutes premières interviews que je
faisais et honnêtement je ne sais pas ce
que j'ai pu baragouiner je pense pas que
c'était très audible elle m'avait
expliqué qu imposerait de trois
questions assez basique du genre vous
allez manger quoi vous allez dormir
combien de temps un
comme si finalement le nombre de
kilomètres devait être proportionnelle à
la taille des cuisses et bien vous savez
quoi
pas à pas j'ai monté mon projet et pas à
part j'ai réussi à boucler mon tour du
monde
après trente trois mille kilomètres et
17 mois d'expédition alors évidemment ça
n'a pas été vraiment toujours très
simple tout le monde regarde
l'hélicoptère je suppose mais personne
n'a remarqué le petit point jaune je
vois que tout le monde suit c'est bien
le petit point jaune c'est moi qui tape
une brasse on est en mer de béring je me
dis bien la mer de béring et non pas le
dès le 3 tout le monde connaît le
détroit
la mer de béring c'est entre l'alaska et
la sibérie
j'envisage de rejoindre de l'alaska la
fin je prévois pardon de rejoindre la
sibérie à partir de l'alaska en kayak
400 kilomètres au milieu une île toute
petite île ça fait six jours je navigue
je prévois d'arriver sur l'île d'ici
quelques heures il fait beau il fait bon
tout va bien j'ai un petit vent de 15
noeuds d'un coup le vent se lève
20 30 40 noeuds en l'espace de une heure
peut-être je me retrouve enfermé dans
mon kayak dans des creux de 5 à 6 mètres
le vent souffle sa table dans tous les
sens mon kayak pour situer c'est un
espace de vie de 50 cm de large 36 cm de
haut 1 mètre 90 de long un jour
quelqu'un m'a dit mais c'est la
dimension d'un cercueil ton truc
pas fou c'est moins capitonné mais pas
faux eh bien je décide de résister je
désire s'il décide de rester dedans de
m'enfermer d'attendre il faut savoir que
le kayakiste et 50 kg ch et 50 kg de
matériel et 50 kg de vivre enfin bref 50
kg et à cette époque là je faisais à peu
près 50 kg donc ma position dans le
kayak est cruciale il faut que je reste
allongé au fond du kayak les marques
comme ça pour éviter que le kayak se
retourne parce que si jamais le kayak se
retourne et j'ai une chance je finis au
fond de l'eau avec les poissons loué à
deux degrés 1 c'est là ce que je résiste
comme ça pendant 36 heures au bout de 36
heures je suis obligé d'appeler les
garde-côtes il faut savoir que cette
décision elle vous paraît évidente
peut-être a été une des décisions les
plus difficiles de toute ma vie parce
que au moment où j'appelle les
garde-côtes
c'est tout mon projet je laisse derrière
moi je cours pas après la gloire ni une
coupe je fais pas une compétition
j'ai pas un chèque à l'arrivée mais ça
fait des années que je travaille sur ce
projet ce projet a donné un sens à ma
vie
quand je me retrouve tout seul et que
j'appelle les garde-côtes c'est mon
projet que je laisse tomber
cette décision a été une des plus
difficiles de toute ma vie
pour autant je pense que si
l'hélicoptère avait mis une heure de
plus pour venir me chercher je serais
pas là aujourd'hui pour vous en parler
tout ne se passe pas toujours comme
prévu
les cas de le dire
et bien après 17 mois d'expédition j'ai
rejoint la france et j'ai créé une
entreprise depuis six ans je me consacre
au développement de cette entreprise là
j'ai la chance d'avoir deux enfants
formidables que j'emmène tous les matins
ou presque à l'école et même s'il envie
de faire des projets est restée intacte
et bien aujourd'hui suis concentré là
dessus mais petit à petit j'entreprends
de nouveaux projets d' aventure on est
entre nous
vous êtes plutôt un public formidable je
peux vous le dire j'envisage de faire le
vendée globe
merci c'est gentil je prends mais on va
attendre quand même d y arriver
ceci étant je sens déjà dans la foule et
je vous ai vu vous madame
sourire je sens déjà dans la foule qu'il
ya certains qui se disent mais il peut
pas y arriver connaît rien à la voile il
n'a pas d'expérience il n'est pas dans
la case grand marin ou dans la case
breton il n'a pas le physique de
kersauson favre marquerait je suis pas
très loin de celui d' ellen macarthur
c'est peut-être méchant
vous savez quoi
j'en sais rien peut-être que j'y
arriverai peut-être que j'y arriverai
pas et au fond ça n'a pas vraiment
d'importance
vous savez pourquoi parce que je crois
que les succès sont des catalyseurs et
les échecs des opportunités
rien d'autre en revanche si je veux être
certain d'avancer dans la bonne
direction
être certain de mes choix il faut que
ses choix soient guidés par les envies
et non mes chances de succès je sais pas
si j'arriverai et après tout ça m'était
ça m'est complètement égal
parce que si vous voulez être certain
d'avancer dans la bonne direction
vos choix doivent être guidés par vos
envies alors voila si j'ai une idée
simple à partager avec vous arrêtez de
vous poser trente six mille questions
l'impossible est tout sauf impensable
alors allez-y